una cosa non naturalmente è creata
hines e di costume della confezione di
chi l'ha prodotta
per questo la responsabilità individuale
delle quantità
diventa argomento corale di una società
che non può altrimenti definirsi tale le
scelte culturali di una comunità e dei
suoi cittadini si misurano sul raggio di
dominanza in sicko delle osservazioni
la definizione
con lo sguardo
ufficiale a un tempo breve gela cultura
che dura poco consumistica una cultura
usa e getta
la riflessione sul futuro è doveroso
design di vita lo sguardo di un artista
o di un autore che applica una
trasformazione prepartita di una cosa è
ciò che può svelare la strada accetti
viaggiatori erranti l'analisi
intellettuale di un artista si basa
spesso sulla verità di concetti e donne
che aprì rifiutano talvolta disprezzano
quanto meno
no non considerano la funzione di
commentatori del sociale ed evolute
consacrata alla loro sensibilità
impazzita economia patologica a un
antidoto infallibile nel genio creativo
umano la nostra casa comune va tutelata
attraverso scelte culturali che sono la
portata di tutti basta un minimo di
conoscenza o semplicemente un attenzione
ogni individuo è protagonista delle
radiazioni e le azioni senza coscienza
non sono specificatamente ormonale se un
individuo senza essa fare i nomi single
azione e se l'azione genera una cosa
l'essenza stessa frase nella cosa tra
cosa quindi ha un'essenza
una cultura usa e getta
non dobbiamo assolutamente creare questo
tipo di città la nostra città è composta
da cose e da uomini e da persone questa
è la città più a marzo ho proposto al
comune di albano un evento dal nome
l'etica in una cosa è esattamente si è
svolto in una bellissima con so che è
l'ex chiesa di santa maria delle grazie
sconsacrata quelli dove abbiamo composto
una tre giorni molto dinamica
ho diretto questo questo evento un frate
espositivo e performativo nonché di
laboratori e dibattiti sull'ambiente
attraverso l'arte l'arte l'artigianato
il design di ornamenti da ingrosso
quindi attraverso la creatività umana
il passaggio attraverso gli artisti
sulla riflessione ambientale e cittadina
per tenuti cittadino
gli autori partecipanti a questo a
questo evento artistico ambientale erano
degli artisti di arte contemporanea arti
visive
lui si chiama alessandro nicola ed è uno
scultore tutti loro partecipavano con
delle creazioni come le opere
assolutamente tutte composte con
materiale di riciclo
qui al san nicola uno sciatore ancora un
altro istruttore di troppo la foto di
postura quindi non si vede molto bene
comunque un altro scultore che riesce
con dei dati
adesso belli riesce con dei rottami a
comporre delle forme di stampo
classicistico e 6
abbiamo importanti in altri caracol
eleonora battaggia è una creatrice
veneta che ha partecipato con questi
suoi ornamenti da indosso il pc abbiamo
allestito un altare intero dedicato a
lei e ai suoi anelli alle sue collane e
alla sua civiltà che era una città
composta ovviamente esclusivamente con
dei pezzi di stoffa dal triciclo lei co
centri che sono due creative 2
noi contemporanee che lavorano tra roma
i castelli romani a loro studi e
compongono per loro oggetti di design
con il cantone principalmente pediconi
cantone creano questa poltrona o
l'estate vederlo
evasiva sempre ragazze giovanissime la
grafica design
delle arti visive ma che agiva che si
sono unite per creare dei pc con dei
mari
in questo caso sono
collana composta da palloncini gonfiati
avanti dice francesca la pignola lei è
una creativa una restauratrice una
persona che ha fatto completamente
aleardi e ha scoperto un materiale la
cartapesta che ha vinto corso e quindi
sviluppa delle figurine microscopiche
questa è una serie che si chiama
teatrini ed è piccolissimo quindi sono
delle cose estremamente delicate
estremamente a grazie a materiali
lui è francesco vale sanno questa era
queste erano delle lettere composte con
un materiale creato da scarti di cartone
di gesso insieme poi amalgamate un
lavoro estremamente complesso
gino casavecchia un designer riallestito
qui
in particolare dei suoi piatti in pietra
aveva allestito un ultima cena
all'interno
cautela
perché si sa
grazie con questi impianti questa tavola
apparecchiata con castiglia utilizzato
nella terapia e tralasciano le strade in
raffaella liscio è una stilista che
compone fuori abile con materiale di
riciclo principalmente la plastica
questa regale rappresentazione di donna
è vestita con dei sacchetti è iniziato
tutto il suo vestito è capito qualcosa
che contrastava muto con l'evento con
l'arte alta con l'estetica con la fredda
e quindi lasci del ca diventarla proprio
anche nel manifesto del catalogo di film
abbiamo passato tanti favori per vini
artista locale e lui anche si produce
soprattutto con dei gatti
a dipingere compone queste visioni
cittadini comunitari della nostra e line
cittadino alcuni scorci fida di mio per
poi creare andare a concorrere per i
particolari
umberto romagnoli è un fotografo di
albano che si è occupato di un bel
progetto di cui che ha fatto meno secolo
e io sul nostro lago danno e quindi
un po quello che è avvenuto a queste
rocce a queste rocce che fino a pochi
anni fa si trovavano sotto il livello
delle acque della be adesso sono uscite
fuori di dire qualcosa che aveva a che
fare con il nostro
andiamo avanti noi abbiamo fatto dei
dibattiti sull'ambiente abbiamo parte
dei lavoratori per i bambini creativi
con materiali di riciclo
abbiamo bloccarlo un povero di mercatino
del baratto fa in poi mercanti nel
tempio forse era un
poi fuori norma
e poi io ho presentato una performance
su josé artista tedesco del punto che ha
impostato la sua arte attraverso se
stesso e attraverso la natura e
l'ambiente quindi una opera una sua
opera si chiamava proprio la rivoluzione
siamo noi
quindi il contesto unico
le nostre idee e soprattutto della
nostra creatività che riesce a comporre
a creare una finalità di società di vita
di comunità che è senz'altro migliore in
questa vergogna andiamo avanti
avevo è noioso boys e quindi avevo suo
immancabile cappello di feltro stavo
fatto delle performance che i nostri poi
sarà presentato in più occasioni e avevo
anche la natura il quinto con quel ramo
fiore 5
non so cosa perché bianco e un diciamo
di ispirazione concettuale per
rafforzare questo rapporto che è un
rapporto unico qui noi come gipi qui
siamo unici
le nostre idee sono la nostra creatività
unita
quindi andando a cercare tutto questo si
compone una una vita una società che è
proprio lo specchio di quello che vi
siano più sensibili tantissima più
creabili tace e più si compone una
società migliore più si congiungono cose
la città è composta da cose e dagli
uomini
quindi se noi riusciamo a rafforzare
questi due concetti a credere su questi
due
abbiamo vinto la nostra città l'ultima
diapositiva si riferisce a questa frase
molto significativa che che di 6 o se
poi se prima di morire
questa fiamma questo questa fiamma che
abbiamo dentro
non dobbiamo mai farla spegnere dobbiamo
sempre valido
parla la fiamma e la nostra individua in
difficoltà la nostra voglia di di essere
di essere unici ma all'interno berti e
composti da una comunità grazie